[Music]
[Music]
iron man
here in this video we will discuss one
important topic that ties in both the
events of avengers and game and the
eternals the question is did the
infinity stones kill off half of all the
celestials or did it even have any
effect on them or the celestial seeds
well stately and to know the answer to
this topic and watch the video fully to
understand why we come to our eventual
conclusion
this is also kind of like a comparison
of powers wheeled by the celestials
against the potential powers of all the
infinity stones together
so subscribe if you haven't and now
let's get down with this sickness
let's talk a little bit on the origins
of the infinity stones well the infinity
stones were six immensely powerful
gem-like objects tied to different
aspects of the universe created by the
big bang from six singularities the big
bang then form concentrated crystals out
of them and send the six stones hurling
throughout the universe
each stone represented a different
aspect of the universe space mind
reality power time and the soul only
beings of immense power can directly
wield them such as celestials and the
mad titan thanos without dying others
can use them but at their own peril
now let's take a look on the origin of
the celestials in the mcu they were
stated to have existed before the
universe even began and even before the
infinity stones were created the
celestials are the universe's oldest
rays they were present before the birth
of creation and were responsible for
bringing planets and life forms from all
around the universe they used their
boundless cosmic power to create planet
stars and life forms as well as bring
light to the universe and stop the
darkness from seed to emergence a normal
celestion's life cycle takes many
millennia to complete arashim the prime
celestial recreated that every few
million years some celestials must be
born
so what are the extent of the powers of
the infinity stones let's take this
first
each stone on its own has immense power
by themselves the power stone grants the
user power to defeat even the most
powerful foes the time stone can help
the user manipulate time the space stone
can transport anyone to any place in the
universe instantly the reality stone can
change the fabric of reality the mind
stone is able to control sentient life
forms and do other mental stuff as well
and lastly the soul stone which unites
all the others to form a unified sixth
together the infinity stones can wipe
out half of all life forms in the
universe and that is not their full
extent they can even undo the entire
universe as well if the user wishes to
as in the case of thanos in end game
attempting to do so in the end of the
movie
now what about the extent of the powers
of the celestials they are cosmic
creatures of unimaginable power and
magnitude they are immortal able to live
indefinitely without dying of old age
the only way one was killed was when the
eternals after combining their cosmic
energies with tiemout himself to form
the unimine something that would have
only occurred due to the celestial's own
will to die celestials are able to
manipulate massive amounts of cosmic
energy in order to generate stars life
and planets so being a celestial means
being the greatest energy generators in
the cosmos they are able to travel
instantly everywhere using black holes
and change size at will as well as
communicate telepathically but are they
able to withstand the powers of the
infinity stones
so firstly let's go to the part when isa
and the searcher as celestial used the
power stone to augment his powers and he
was one of the celestials who was seen
in a scene shown by the collector to the
guardians of the galaxy when he was
destroying a planet full of life and he
did this by using a power stone this
brings us to question the extent of the
powers of a celestial if they are the
universe's most potent energy generators
capable of creating stars and planets
why did one need an infinity stone to
destroy a planet when he could have
easily done so with cosmic energy what
if arishim the judge was just lying to
everyone about how powerful the
celestials are given the fact that he
has already lied about the eternals
being from olympia tiamet emergence
destroying the earth the eternal's true
purpose there and other things as well
so side by side this brings in another
question what did thanos and the hulk's
infinity stone snap do to them and the
universe and did this snap affect the
celestial's emergence or their
population across the universe
well thanos's snap in the end of
infinity war did reduce the entire
population of life across the universe
by half which means trillions and
trillions of lives all over the cosmos
and with recent revelations of thanos
and arrows themselves being eternals
from the planet titan it would be safe
to assume that thanos was also targeting
the celestials as well but why did he
just use the infinity stones against
them and spare the entire universe's
population was the mad titan just mad or
was it really done but not shown at all
or did it have any effect on the
celestials
so what's the conclusion well the
celestials did emerge before the
infinity stones were created since they
were here before the universe began and
because of this they might have a bit of
immunity to the powers of the infinity
stones but then again
we have already seen ego being killed by
analogue's batteries nukes another
severed head of a celestial that became
the mining colony called nowhere and now
teamwork being turned into stone so
since all three of these were killed by
relatively conventional powers and
weapons that can't match with the
magnitude of infinity stones in a
gauntlet then doesn't it mean that the
celestials can be killed in a snap
and in the movie eternals they did say
that the snap brought about the
necessary energy for the emergence of
celestials so there should be some
connection between them
so it is ultimately for the mcu writers
and producers to decide this but if it
was up to us then we would say that
thanos's snap did erase half of the
population of the universe and also the
celestial seeds within planets as well
and since the infinity stones were that
powerful they would be able to at least
wipe out half the population of the
celestials but
only those who were born after the
universe began the ones like ereshim who
existed before the creation of the
stones would have more power and
resistance to their effect and therefore
would not have been wiped out but that's
just our theory if you have your own
then put it down in the comments below
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam